This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。你有帮助他人做出改变的渴望吗？拉西特学院为你提供“依赖与伴侣”项目。获取相关技能
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
这些技能对于陪伴和支持面临健康和依赖问题的人至关重要。开启一段丰富的职业生涯，为
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
全国各地的法语社区服务。如果您想精通法语，这完全可以通过
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
拉西特学院实现。今天就访问Collage LaC. .A.，这是国家法语健康培训联盟发起的一项倡议，得到了加拿大卫生部的支持。那些眼睛里毫无生机。它们变成了黑色。吓死我了。恶魔，醒醒。我是亲眼目睹
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
克里瓦奇和德皮波行凶的那个女人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出一丝悔意，在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我要把这起案件上诉到底。在iHeart Radio应用程序、
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷》中的“恶魔采石场”。快乐至关重要，它也同样难以捉摸，但现在有一个全新且令人兴奋的方式来开启您的旅程
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
去追求更快乐的生活。《快乐101》。这是一个全新的播客，由我，霍达·科特比主持。如果您渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的现场聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。由CVS为您呈现的霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情感共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这只是一些关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯，
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums.
欢迎在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们正在与文化界最炙手可热的名字对话，比如斯韦·李。你意识到自己有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我经常看到它，但我心里想，天哪，我还有，比如，还有更多的事情要做。就像普林斯，他发行了大约30张专辑。
We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversation. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here.
我们现在才发行了大约五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。是的，这是一种好态度。无论哪个时代，《Drink Chams》都会为您带来最大牌的人物和最原汁原味的对话。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Chams》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里。
back for another episode, back for a very important episode of the psychology of your 20s. You know what I always find so weird about being alive in this day and age? We have so much information and so much knowledge about literally everything. We know what stars are made of. We know how old trees are. We understand complex maths. We just sent like, what was it, like eight people to the moon? schools will teach you all these things. They will literally spend 15 years teaching you
欢迎收听另一期节目，欢迎收听《20多岁的心理学》中非常重要的一期节目。你知道我觉得在这个时代活着最奇怪的一点是什么吗？我们拥有如此多的信息和知识，几乎涵盖了一切。我们知道星星是由什么组成的。我们知道树木有多老。我们理解复杂的数学。我们刚刚把，大概是什么来着，大约八人送上了月球？学校会教给你所有这些东西。他们会花足足15年的时间教你
what essentially ends up amounting to fun facts. And no one will ever talk about like the crucial foundational things to do with friendships, to do with relationships, to do with maintaining connections. Like despite them being the most important parts of being alive, I was never taught how to tell if like somebody is just using you. I was never taught how to deal with conflict in the family. And I was definitely never given any formal or even informal instruction on how to repair and mend a friendship. And I would bet a lot of money that neither were you. So I wanted to talk about it today and just see what was out there in terms of the best and worst ways to go about tricky situations with your friends. There's so much emphasis
基本上最终只是有趣的事实的东西。然而却没有人会谈论那些至关重要的基础事情，比如如何处理友谊，如何处理人际关系，如何维持联系。尽管它们是活着的最重要的部分，但我从来没有被教导过如何判断一个人是否只是在利用你。我从来没有被教导过如何处理家庭冲突。而且绝对没有人给我提供任何正式的甚至是内行的指导，教我如何修复和弥补一段友谊。我敢打赌，你也没有。所以我今天想谈谈这个，看看在面对与朋友之间的棘手情况时，有哪些最好和最糟糕的方法。现在有如此多的强调
these days as well on building community and being the villager. Like that is everywhere you see, everywhere you look online, somebody is posting or talking about how to make friends offline, how to be a better neighbor and all that stuff. And I actually rarely see people talk about the less attractive parts of that, which is fighting with friends, how to handle conflict, why it's normal to be annoyed with the people you care about and how to get through that, how to survive some of the deepest hurts coming from your friends. I feel like it is this major gap in our understanding and conversations as humans that never gets talked about. And as somebody who has had some pretty serious friendships,
在这些日子里，关于建立社区和成为一个村民也是如此。就像你在网上看到的、到处都能看到的东西一样，每个人都在发帖或谈论如何在现实生活中交朋友，如何成为一个更好的邻居等等。而我实际上很少看到人们谈论其中不太吸引人的一部分，那就是与朋友吵架，如何处理冲突，为什么对你关心的人生气是正常的以及如何度过难关，如何从朋友带来的最深的伤害中恢复过来。我觉得这是我们人类理解和对话中的一个重大空白，却从来没有人谈论过。作为一个在过去五年里经历过相当严重友谊破裂的人，
like explosions in the past five years and in my 20s, some of which were entirely my fault, but some of which were just good old-fashioned miscommunication. I just feel like this is the hard, no-nonsense advice I still need, but have needed for having awkward conversations with the people that I love who are my friends. So without further ado, let's get into our guide on how to repair a friendship. In my opinion, friendship fallouts are like a life-defining pain in many ways. Like falling out with your friends, arguing with your friends, having conflict can change the course of our lives at times. I also think losing a friend, is a form of grief that no one wants to get into. Nobody wants to touch that. Nobody talks about it
比如在我20多岁的时候经历过彻底的闹翻，其中有些完全是我的错，但也有些只是老式的沟通误解。我只是觉得这是我仍然需要的、但为了与我所爱且作为朋友的人进行尴尬的对话而一直需要的坚定、直截了当的建议。所以废话不多说，让我们进入关于如何修复友谊的指南。在我看来，友谊的破裂在许多方面就像是一种决定人生的痛苦。就像与朋友闹翻、与朋友争吵、产生冲突有时会改变我们生活的轨迹。我也认为失去一个朋友，是一种没有人愿意涉及的悲伤。没有人想碰触这个话题。没有人谈论它
enough, probably because we devalue the necessity of friendship in the modern world and we kind of see them as expendable. I really think that friendship fallouts can be even more devastating than romantic ones. When you have a romantic breakup, people around you, like, they know how to treat you. There's like an agreed upon grieving period. They know that like you're going to be very sad. They know to throw ice cream at the situation, but when it's a friend, people just kind of expect you to be normal. I also think there are like unconscious rules for fighting in a relationship, right? You kind of know in a relationship that you need to resolve things between like 24 and 72 hours. You're a lot more dependent on each other so there's like more humility. You know, if you can't get through it,
足够多，可能是因为我们贬低了现代世界中友谊的必要性，而我们有点把它们看作是可有可无的。我真的认为友谊的破裂甚至比浪漫关系的破裂更具毁灭性。当你经历了一次浪漫的分手时，你身边的人，他们知道如何对待你。有一个双方默认的悲伤期。他们知道你会非常难过。他们知道该用冰淇淋来应对这种情况，但当对象是朋友时，人们只会期望你表现得正常。我也认为恋爱关系中存在着无形的不成文的争吵规则，对吧？在恋爱关系中，你大概知道你需要在24到72小时之间解决问题。你们彼此更加依赖，所以会有更多的谦逊。你知道，如果你无法度过难关，
you just break up and that's it. Like you break up. You can be fighting with a friend for like months. and it can linger in a way it doesn't with a partner. You can at times never get to a resolution and just like never speak again. And eventually like you are just these two strangers who for a time loved and cared for each other and now you just have this weird baggage you don't even really understand anymore. I think friendships, we expect them to be these super steady things. We expect them to be our most dependable relationships. in many ways, they are not.
你们就分手，就这样。就像你们分手一样。你可能会和朋友吵上几个月。而且它可能会以一种与伴侣不同的方式挥之不去。有时你可能永远无法达成和解，而只是再也不说话。最后，你只是变成了这两个陌生人，他们曾经彼此相爱、关心，而现在你们只留下了这种奇怪的、甚至不再真正理解的包袱。我认为对于友谊，我们期望它们是超级稳定的事情。我们期望它们是我们最值得依赖的关系。但在许多方面，它们并非如此。
And the older you get, you realize how much conflict does actually show up in friendship. I would say there are three types of friendship breakups. The fizzle, the blow up, and the miscommunication. First is the slow fizzle. We have all experienced this. I'm so sure of it. Time just simply, like, changes the strength of a bond. A close friendship becomes less close.
随着年龄的增长，你会意识到冲突在友谊中实际上是多么常见。我想说，友谊的分手有三种类型。逐渐疏远、彻底闹翻和沟通误解。首先是慢慢疏远。我们都经历过这一点。我对此深信不疑。时间只会简单地改变纽带的强度。一段亲密的友谊变得不再那么亲密。
You kind of gently fade away from each other's lives. You see each other less. you catch up less. And it's, I think personally, it gets to a stage where it's like mutually understood that you're both a little bit okay with it. This might be because of distance. Classic example is like after you leave uni, but also somebody gets into a relationship, somebody gets a partner and that just like completely disrupts the dynamic. I think especially in our 20s, this is like the most major source of the fizzle, especially amongst really close friends, like somebody gets a partner and the central relationship is replaced and the center
你们在彼此的生活中逐渐温和地淡出。你们见面变少了。你们叙旧变少了。而且我认为，个人觉得，它会达到一个阶段，就是双方都心照不宣地觉得彼此都能接受这一点。这可能是因为距离。经典的例子就像是你大学毕业离开后，但也有可能是某人谈恋爱了，某人有了伴侣，这完全扰乱了动态。我认为尤其是在我们的20多岁，这是疏远的最主要来源，特别是在非常要好的朋友之间，比如有人有了伴侣，核心关系就被取代了，
of orbit shifts from your friends to the person you're romantically interested in, whether we like it or not. Meaning you just become like less available. The friendship slowly diminishes because you're not having those opportunities for like close contact. That is the first friendship fallout that we typically see. We also. can fall out with our friends because of communication. This is like a classic situation. Nobody is distinctly in the wrong, but both people have a hard time or are unable to understand the other person's perspective. Both people are wounded by the miscommunication. And often, or maybe it's just one person, but often neither person, either one person doesn't really know what's going on, what's
不管我们愿意与否，生活的重心从你的朋友转移到了你心仪的浪漫对象身上。这意味着你变得不那么容易联系了。友谊慢慢减弱，因为你们没有了密切接触的机会。这是我们通常看到的第一次友谊破裂。我们也会。因为沟通问题而与朋友闹翻。这就像是一个典型的情况。没有人绝对有错，但双方都很难或无法理解对方的视角。双方都因沟通不畅而受到伤害。通常，或者也许只有一个人，但通常两个人中，要么一个人真的不知道发生了什么，什么
going on, or neither person is really willing to recognize, like, that the other person didn't hurt the matter of ill intent. Like, they just are left with the wound separate from the intention. And so it's kind of hard to be around them, or you just kind of never get around to talking to this person. And so either you let it linger, or it does end up becoming the fizzle. And then we have the full-on friendship blowout. And I think this gets all the attention, right? We are talking about someone or both people doing something really bad, severely violating trust, betrayal, situations that just expose deep cracks in the friendship. Somebody has done something deeply inconsiderate. Somebody has broken promises.
发生了什么，要么两个人都不愿意承认，比如对方并没有恶意去伤害。他们只是留下了脱离了最初意图的伤口。所以很难和他们相处，或者你根本没有时间和这个人说话。所以要么你让它拖延下去，要么它最终确实变成了逐渐疏远。然后我们迎来了全面的友谊彻底破裂。我认为这受到了所有的关注，对吧？我们谈论的是某人或双方做了非常糟糕的事情，严重违背了信任，背叛，这些情况暴露了友谊中深深的裂痕。某人做了极其不体贴的事。某人打破了诺言。
Maybe somebody has hurt even the people that you love, like family, other friends of yours, your partner in a way that you really never expected them to. these can be these these are these not can be these are painful and intense i also think that of those three of the fizzle the miscommunication and the and the blow up sometimes these are the easiest to recover from because a moment like that of just like such just like just like just a nuclear bomb on the friendship you kind of know the friendship is dead like there's just a certainty there that other friendship fallouts don't always have like obviously all of them all the of them hurt. All of these situations are painful. That's definitely for sure. You're losing somebody who is like really steady or you're losing somebody that you really care about. But I think
也许有人甚至伤害了你所爱的人，比如你的家人、你的其他朋友、你的伴侣，伤害的程度超出了你从未料想的预期。这些可能是，这些不是可能，这些是痛苦且激烈的。我也认为，在这三种情况——疏远、沟通误解和闹翻——之中，有时这些是最容易恢复的，因为经历那样一个时刻，就像是对友谊投下了一枚核弹，你内心其实知道友谊已经死了，有一种其他友谊破裂不常有的确定感，就像显然它们所有的情况都带来了痛苦。所有这些情况都是痛苦的。那是绝对肯定的。你失去了一个非常稳定的人，或者你失去了一个你真的很在乎的人。但我认为
when it comes to the major fallouts, the closure is like in the story. When it comes to the fizzle, when it comes to the miscommunication, that's where things get complicated. But I also think those are the situations that we can recover from and that we're kind of focusing. on today. Moments that are really uncomfortable, moments that feel difficult, that feel, let's just be real, awkward, but where I think if you just put a little bit of effort into saving the relationship, it can be mended if you have the tools. So let's talk about it. How do we repair these kinds of situations? I think the first step, the major step, is understanding the psychology behind why we avoid confrontation and why we avoid admitting our mistakes.
当谈到重大的决裂时，结局就已经写在故事里了。而当谈到疏远、谈到沟通误解时，事情就变得复杂了。但我也认为这些是我们可以从中恢复的情况，也是我们今天要关注的焦点。那些让人真正感到不舒服的时刻，那些感觉困难、感觉——老实说——尴尬的时刻，但在我看来，如果你付出一点点努力去拯救这段关系，只要你掌握了方法，它就能得到修复。所以让我们来谈谈。我们如何修复这类情况？我认为第一步，也是最重要的一步，是理解我们为什么逃避对抗以及为什么逃避承认错误的心理学。
Considering how important friendship is, literally there have been studies after studies showing they're the most valuable thing for our health and well-being in our lives, it still does always fascinate me how hard it is for us to fight for them. I'm very guilty of this myself. Like, I probably don't even want to admit it to myself that I am guilty of this, but I know I am. and there's a science as to why we have this kind of avoidance. 90% of it is ego and not in the like, I'm better than everybody kind of way, I'm the shit kind of way, in the self-protection way. Our ego, this is something I always impress on people when I talk about ego.
考虑到友谊是如此重要，事实上有一项又一项的研究表明，它们是我们生活中对健康和福祉最有价值的东西，但令我着迷的依然是，为它们而战竟然是如此艰难。我自己对此深感愧疚。比如，我可能甚至不想向自己承认我对此感到愧疚，但我知道我是。而且我们之所以有这种回避心理，是有科学依据的。90%是出于自我（ego），而且不是那种“我比所有人都好”的那种自大，不是那种“我很了不起”的心态，而是出于自我保护。我们的自我，这是我每当谈到“自我”时总是向人们强调的一点。
It is not just responsible for our self-esteem. It is responsible for helping us to avoid all feelings of pain, all feelings of rejection or disappointment that may run counter to our internal sense of stability. That means that it can often cause us to act in very irrational ways just so that we feel safe in our idea of ourselves and in our idea and our concept of the world. Our ego though, because of this function, it just ends up like getting in the way of being able to admit that you're wrong. Like it is this big, our ego is this big guard that stops us from ever feeling bad about ourselves. However, that causes problems when we're trying to repair a friendship because it means that admitting that we're wrong becomes
它不仅负责我们的自尊。它还负责帮我们避开所有痛苦的感觉，避开所有可能与我们内在的稳定感相违背的被拒绝或失望的感觉。这意味着它经常会导致我们做出非常不理智的行为，仅仅是为了让我们在对自己的看法以及对世界的看法和概念中感到安全。然而，由于这一功能，我们的自我最终会妨碍我们承认自己错了。就像这是一个巨大的阻碍，我们的自我是一个巨大的防线，阻止我们对自己的感觉产生任何糟糕的体验。然而，当我们试图修复友谊时，这就会引发问题，因为这意味着承认我们错了会变得
incredibly difficult and opposed to our intrinsic psychological sense of self-righteousness. It makes it really hard to come to the realization that we may not be the person we think we are. we are flawed we are sometimes impulsive we are sometimes in the wrong sometimes we have we are the unkind ones when we fall out with a friend right the the chaos of that emotion and the surge of emotion to defend and rationalize our actions and to protect our ego often often does the thing, does the opposite thing to what we should be doing? It's just there to make us feel superior. When we are in these situations where people are hurt, being superior is like the last thing that we should be prioritizing. But we cannot help it. That instinct to defend an attack is
极其困难，并且与我们内在的心理正义感背道而驰。这使得我们很难意识到：我们可能并不是自己所想的那样完美。我们是有缺陷的，我们有时是冲动的，我们有时是错的，有时当我们在与朋友闹翻时，我们是不友善的那一方，对吧？那种情绪的混乱以及为了捍卫和合理化我们的行动、保护我们的自我而涌现的情绪，往往会产生与我们应该做的事情完全相反的效果？它只是为了让我们感觉高人一等。当我们处于这种有人受到伤害的情况时，表现得高高在上应该是我们最不该优先考虑的事情。但我们无法控制。这种防御和攻击的本能是
incredibly strong. I think this is also exacerbated by this sunk cost feeling. when we've committed to something, to a point of view, to us being right, it becomes harder for us to leave that behind. We become very entrenched in it. Obviously, this can happen in so many situations. It happens with relationships. It happens with jobs. And then, of course, it does happen with our experiences and it happens with our arguments and it happens with our feelings. And it causes the strange situation where deep down, we know we need to amend our perspective. We know there are things that we need to admit to, but this deeper unconscious part of us keeps blocking us from doing so. This is like an interesting tidbit, an interesting sidebar. Studies have shown that
极其强烈的。我认为这也因为这种沉没成本的感觉而加剧了。当我们致力于某事、某种观点、确信自己是正确的时候，我们就更难将其抛在脑后。我们对它根深蒂固。显然，这种情况可能发生在许多情况下。它发生在恋爱关系中。它发生在工作中。然后，当然，它确实会发生在我们的经历中，发生在我们的争论中，也发生在我们的感情中。它导致了这样一种奇怪的情况：在内心深处，我们知道我们需要修正自己的观点。我们知道有些事情我们需要承认，但我们内心更深处的无意识部分却一直在阻止我们这样做。这是一个有趣的趣闻，一个有趣的插曲。研究表明，
young women in particular stay angry towards their female friends for longer because of this mechanism, especially compared to men. And what they think it is is because social standing and the threat of social rejection is a lot stronger for women. They feel a deeper sense that they need to protect themselves. A study from 2014 had students role play, a real conflict scenario from their own lives. They recorded the male responses, the female responses. And again, they found that women reported their anger dissipated a lot less quickly. and it took them longer to reconcile. Their heart rate was also higher.
由于这种机制，年轻女性尤其是对女性朋友的愤怒会持续更长时间，特别是与男性相比。他们认为原因在于，对女性而言，社会地位以及遭到社会排斥的威胁要强烈得多。她们有一种更深的需要保护自己的本能。2014年的一项研究让学生们角色扮演他们自己生活中真实的冲突场景。他们记录了男性的反应和女性的反应。结果再次表明，女性报告她们的愤怒消散得慢得多，
Social conflict impacted them on a more psychological and emotional level than it did for men. And I don't want you to take these results out of context and be like, women are emotional, women are insecure, women are just these like pea brain, whatever, whatever. It's just that they often stick with their first intuition for longer. So just an interesting fact about the role of the ego and the gender differences. I think the second reason we find it hard to admit our mistakes or really get into the core of the friendship fallout is because of avoidance. And the fact that avoidance feels a lot like control in a situation that is beyond our control, especially if you're an anxious person, especially if you are somebody who is a very socially anxious person.
她们需要更长的时间来和解。她们的心率也更高。社会冲突在心理和情感层面给她们带来的冲击比对男性的冲击更大。我并不希望你们断章取义地曲解这些结果，认为女性是情绪化的、女性是不安全的、女性就是这种大脑发育不全的群体，不管怎样。这只是因为她们往往会在更长的时间里坚持她们的第一直觉。所以，这只是关于自我的作用以及性别差异的一个有趣事实。我认为我们发现自己很难承认错误或真正深入探讨友谊破裂的核心的第二个原因，是逃避。而且逃避这种事实在一种超出我们控制的情况中，感觉非常类似于控制，特别是如果你是一个焦虑的人，特别是如果你是一个社交非常焦虑的人。
Just as we might avoid, I don't know, going to the dentist. You know, we're afraid to get a needle or have a feeling. Just as we avoid those things, we also avoid someone we are disagreeing with. We avoid having what we know is a much needed conversation because we don't want to feel uncomfortable emotions. Emotions like disappointment, anger, sadness, guilt, disrupt our emotional center. And it feels, it makes us feel very out of depth as well to confront somebody else. emotions that are similar to us, like their confusion and their anger. Again, this is not because we are cruel or uncaring. If you are in the situation now where you're like, I know I need to
正如我们可能会逃避，我不知道，去看牙医。你知道，我们害怕打针或者产生某种感觉。正如我们逃避这些事情一样，我们也逃避与我们意见不合的人。我们逃避进行那场我们明知急需进行的对话，因为我们不想感受到不舒服的情绪。失望、愤怒、悲伤、内疚等情绪会扰乱我们的情感中心。而且它让我们在面对他人时感到力不从心。那些与我们相似的情绪，比如他们的困惑和愤怒。再次说明，这并不是因为我们残酷或冷漠。如果你现在正处于这种境地，心里想着：我知道我需要
have this conversation, I cannot do it, it's all because you are trying to maintain emotional control. When we avoid things, we control our emotional world by avoiding disrupting it with short-term disruptions and short-term anxiety and emotional chaos. But the the thing is that's not a real solution. Short-term avoidance. You know, that can lead and often does lead and will lead to long-term resentment, to disappointment, to irreversible harm and feelings of hurt that most importantly increasingly diminish the likelihood that things will ever be fixed. I think that was a double negative. But yeah, increasingly diminished. Like they just continue to diminish the chances that things are going to get better. I also think my final reason
进行这场对话，但我做不到，这一切都只是因为你在试图保持情感控制。当我们逃避事情时，我们通过避免让短期混乱、短期焦虑和情感混乱来打破它，从而控制我们的情感世界。但问题是，那并不是真正的解决方案。短期的逃避。你知道，这可能导致、而且经常确实会导致并将会导致长期的怨恨、失望、不可逆转的伤害和受伤感，最重要的是，这会日益降低事情得到解决的可能性。我觉得那是个双重否定。但是是的，日益降低。就像它们只会不断减弱事情会变好的机会。我也认为我最后的理由
why I think that we avoid these kind of situations is because oftentimes we're waiting for a clarity about the situation that we think only comes from distance, right? Like we probably don't know how to feel about the friendship. We're kind of a bit confused about what we want from the friendship because things are so like, have changed so quickly because we don't have all the information. And so we, like, we delude ourselves into thinking in that, like, state of ambiguity that the more we think about the situation, the more we get others' opinions, the more we let the dust settle, the more clearly we will start to see things as they are. But in my experience, this is just putting off, putting off the, like, the ability to really tackle the core emotion.
为什么我认为我们逃避这种局面的原因是，往往我们在等待一种对局势的清晰认识，而我们认为这种清晰度只能通过保持距离来获得，对吧？就像我们可能不知道该对这段友谊作何感想。我们有点困惑，不知道自己对这段友谊有什么期望，因为事情发生得太快了，因为我们没有所有的信息。因此，我们，就像，我们在那种模棱两可的状态下自欺欺人，认为我们对情况思考得越多，我们得到的别人意见越多，我们让尘埃落定的时间越多，我们就会越清楚地开始看清事物的本来面目。但在我的经验中，这只是在拖延，拖延了真正解决核心情感的能力，
and I don't think that time ever makes things more clear after a certain point. Obviously, there's immense value in calming down, like after an initial dispute, or after a fight or after a disagreement. That's like emotional regulation 101. But when you keep thinking that an answer will come from talking about it over and over again, especially with people who are not that person or the person you have a problem with, that's avoidance. and speaking from direct personal experience, I think that deep down you probably know what you need
而且我认为在某个特定时间点之后，时间永远不会让事情变得更明朗。显然，在最初的争端之后，或者在争吵或分歧之后，冷静下来具有巨大的价值。那就像是情感调节的101课。但如果你一直认为答案会通过一遍又一遍地谈论它来揭晓，特别是与那些并非当事人或并非与你有问题的人谈论时，那就是逃避。根据我个人的直接经验，我认为在内心深处你可能知道你需要
to do. And I think you know what outcome or what apology or what answer you want. And this applies in all directions, by the way, whether you feel like you're the one responsible for the rift or you're the one who was hurt, you know. And I think repairing a friendship, what this is all telling us, is that it's really just an ego exercise at the end of the day because it means and requires, like, that psychological necessity, number one, is that at some point you will have to admit your fault as a friend. Even if you were 100% right in that situation, even if your only fault is that now you're avoiding saying what you're feeling, it is an ego exercise. It's going to cause you to have to really examine how you may be messed up. So with that in mind, we're going to take a short break
做什么。而且我认为你知道你需要什么结果、什么道歉或什么答案。顺便说一句，这适用于各个方向，无论你觉得你是造成决裂的责任人，还是你是那个受到伤害的人，你其实都知道。我想修复一段友谊，所有这些都在告诉我们，归根结底这其实只是一次自我（ego）的锻炼，因为它意味着并需要，那种心理上的必要性，第一点就是，在某个时刻你将不得不承认你作为朋友的过错。即使你在那种情况下是100%正确的，即使你唯一的过错是现在你在逃避说出自己的感受，这也是一次自我（ego）的锻炼。这将迫使你真正审视自己是如何搞砸的。因此，考虑到这一点，我们将做一个短暂的休息，
and we're just going to get right into it. Step by step, no nonsense guide. How are we going to approach this person, what text message are we going to send them, how are we going to have the conversation? We're going to talk about it after this short break. So stay with us. In Montreal and Oceaga, with four nights at residents in downtown Montreal, flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets, and $1,000 of cash. Please love me. Lord, Zara Larson, Tina Gray, somber, 21 pilots, and more. Download IHard Radio, listen to Iheart new music for 10 minutes, and enter to win. Osiaga, 26.
然后我们就会直接切入正题。一步一步的，直截了当的指南。我们要如何接近这个人，我们要给他们发什么短信，我们要如何进行这场对话？我们将在短暂的休息后讨论这个问题。所以请继续收听。在蒙特利尔和奥西加，包括在蒙特利尔市中心的丽笙酒店住四晚，搭乘波特航空公司的航班，两张周末黄金门票以及1000加元现金。请爱我。Lord、扎拉·拉尔森、蒂娜·格雷、萨姆伯、21飞行员乐队等等。下载IHeart Radio，收听10分钟的Iheart新音乐，即可参与抽奖。奥西加，26。
Every day you listen is another chance to win. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case?
你收听的每一天都是又一次赢取大奖的机会。当时，感觉这一切仿佛无休无止。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里毫无生机。它们变成了黑色。吓死我了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？
Yes, yeah. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo.
是的，是的。敢说这是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀儿童。这已经是最糟糕的情况了。我想是的。人们醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹克里瓦奇和德皮波行凶的目击者。
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. and to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts.
安东尼·德皮波没有表现出一丝悔意，在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我要把它上诉到底。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔的采石场》。想要在Apple Podcasts上免广告并收听独家内容来收听《恶魔的采石场》，请订阅Lava for Good Plus。
Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《由霍达·科特比主持的快乐101》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。我并没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听由霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。
And there's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier Titorito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi?
而且这里有很多令人兴奋的内容，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共存。我仍然有那么多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？
Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barcelona? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out.
外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常的平凡到深邃的非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈。脆弱感在其中流露。
Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me. I'm going to pressurably, but me will be going to be done. It's good. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. And together with IHard Radio,
阴谋论最终被摆上台面，目标和教训被分享。生命中的一切都有着完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等我。我会勉为其难，但我会把它做好。很好。我们来这里是为了建立连接。奇查里托。并且与IHard Radio一起，
we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It's a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The Enhouse is the podcast that's changing that.
我们将把平凡变得不凡。请密切关注。这是一个绝佳的突破。哇。在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《学习做人》。主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的残忍刻画，那些带有羞耻和指责色彩的故事，将无家可归者描绘成一个铁板一块的整体。《我们无家可归》是一档正在改变这一现状的播客。
I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host, and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Weidian Hous is a two-time webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Gio Wichler, a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Let me say, I do think some of what we're about to talk about is going to be fairly obvious. to you, especially if you're like a very emotionally intelligent switched on person, that doesn't mean that we're applying it though.
我是蒂奥·亨德森，创作者兼主持人，多年来我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者能够讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访过无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+群体，以及制定影响无家可归者生存状态的法律的政策制定者。《我们无家可归》是一档荣获两届韦比奖和信号奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾做客。本周收听我对乔·威希勒医生的采访，她是一位从街头医生转型为网红的医生，她对无家可归者社区的工作在网络和她的社区中产生了巨大的影响。在IHard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们无家可归》。我想说，我认为我们接下来要谈论的一些内容对你来说会相当明显。
Just because you know doesn't mean that you're putting it into practice. I think this is a common issue with being a very self-aware individual. Like you can have all the information and number of the execution. So whatever situation you are in right now, I want you to really picture your situation in this context and just consider in every point, like how would I go about this? how am I going to apply this understanding? There's also a big question lingering here as well, which is like, is my friendship worth saving? Is this friendship best left in the past? I think, yeah, some are. Some friendships are best left. They're done, right? The hurt goes too deep.
特别是如果你是一个情商极高、反应敏捷的人，但这并不意味着我们正在将其付诸实践。仅仅因为你知道，并不意味着你正在将其付诸实践。我认为这是一个高度自我觉察的人的常见问题。就像你可以掌握所有的信息，但在执行力上却一窍不通。所以无论你现在处于什么情况，我都希望你在这个背景下真正想象一下你的情况，并在每一点上都思考一下：我会如何处理这件事？我将如何应用这种理解？这里还有一个悬而未决的重大问题，那就是：我的友谊值得挽救吗？这段友谊最好留在过去吗？我想，是的，有些是的。有些友谊最好留在过去。它们结束了，对吧？伤害太深了。
The situation is too unbearable. You don't want to be friends with them anymore. That's just sometimes the outcome. But I think that you're listening to this episode for a reason. And I think when you feel that tug and that lingering sense of like, I miss them, I still care about them. There's something left there. Then it's worth repairing. So the first thing that you're going to do if you want to repair the friendship is just reflect on why you want to mend it.
情况太令人无法忍受了。你不想再和他们做朋友了。有时结果就是这样。但我认为你收听这一集是有原因的。而且我认为当你感觉到那种拉扯感和那种挥之不去的念头，比如“我想念他们，我依然在乎他们，那里还有些东西残留”，那么它就值得修复。因此，如果你想修复这段友谊，你要做的第一件事就是反思你为什么要修复它。
Like what do you seek to gain? There's no point mending a friendship if you don't know why you value the friendship. If you don't know what you want to change. if you don't actually see a future with that person. Just really dig in deep. What is it about this person? Honestly, it's also a great humanizing exercise. What is it about this person that you miss?
比如你期望得到什么？如果你不知道自己为什么珍视这段友谊，那么修复友谊就毫无意义。如果你不知道自己想改变什么。如果你实际上看不到与那个人的未来。那就真的深入挖掘一下。关于这个人，到底是为什么？老实说，这也是一次绝佳的人性化锻炼。关于这个人，你怀念的是什么？
What are your regrets to do with this person? Do you, with this situation, like, do you feel like there's a misunderstanding you could overcome? Do you feel like there are ways that you could both learn from each other? Do you want to mend the friendship to make things less uncomfortable? for an upcoming event? Like, what is your intention? Because they are going to be different, right?
你对这个人有什么遗憾？在这个情况下，你是否觉得有什么误解是你可以克服的？你是否觉得你们可以从彼此身上学到一些东西？你想修复友谊是为了让接下来的某个活动不那么尴尬吗？比如，你的意图是什么？因为它们会是不同的，对吧？
Maybe your intention is like, you feel guilty. And like you feel like you owe them an apology. Everybody's motivation is going to be very, very different. Try and identify what it is that yours is. And the difference between a friendship that you actively want to continue and a situation that you just think deserves closure, but not necessarily the continuation of the relationship. I think both of those situations are equally worthwhile.
也许你的意图是，你感到内疚。并且你觉得你欠他们一个道歉。每个人的动机都会非常非常不同。试着找出你自己的动机是什么。你积极想要继续的友谊，与你认为只配拥有一个结局、但不一定需要延续这段关系的情况，这两者之间是有区别的。我认为这两种情况都同样有价值。
They're both very worthwhile options, right, compared to the alternative of leaving the situation just like open and festering and like never with any closure. But they're going to necessitate a different approach, right? They're both worthwhile, but you're going to have to go about it a little bit differently because wanting a friendship to repair means that you're going to have to do a couple of extra steps, wanting a friendship to just have closure and understanding, kind of means that, you know, there doesn't really need to be behavioral change for the other person. So it's more about like the conversation and it probably could be resolved by a couple of hours of just real deep talking.
它们都是非常值得的选择，对吧，比起那种让情况一直悬而未决、不断溃烂且永无结局的替代方案。但它们需要不同的方法，对吧？它们都很有价值，但你必须采取略有不同的处理方式，因为想要修复一段友谊意味着你必须采取几个额外的步骤，而仅仅想让友谊有个结局和理解，在某种程度上意味着，你知道，另一个人其实不需要发生行为上的改变。所以它更多的是关于对话，而且可能通过几个小时真正的深度交谈就能解决。
So just knowing that is very, very valuable. Secondly, once you've kind of identified your motivation, you have that increased self-awareness around your intentions, I think then the time comes to admit to yourself what you did role or what you could have done better. This might be controversial. If you want to repair a friendship, you need to humble yourself, even if they played a role as well, even if they played the main role. I know people won't agree with this.
所以了解这一点是非常非常有价值的。其次，一旦你确定了你的动机，你对自己的意图有了增强的自我觉察，我认为接下来的时候就是向自己承认你所扮演的角色或者你本可以做得更好的地方。这可能会引起争议。如果你想修复一段友谊，你需要放低姿态，即使他们也扮演了角色，即使他们扮演的是主角。我知道人们不会同意这一点。
this is an ego exercise though and obviously this is probably a miscommunication this is a fizzle it's not a crazy breakdown you going in guns blazing ready to defend yourself and ready to defend your position to the death unable to make any concessions this is not going to be productive right humbling yourself admitting what you have done wrong even if it's just one or two things is important for this for this goal which is to repair the friendship because It's not about scoring points. It's about restoring psychological safety. It's about restoring trust. And when you're unwilling to acknowledge your role, even a small part, I think it signals defensiveness. And I think, and I know, studies show us that defensiveness is the thing that's going to immediately activate the other person's threat response.
但这是一种自我的锻炼，显然这可能是一个误解，这是一次逐渐疏远，这不是一次疯狂的崩溃，你气势汹汹地准备为自己辩护，准备誓死捍卫自己的立场，无法做出任何让步，这不会是富有成效的，对吧？放低姿态，承认你做错了什么，即使只有一两件事，对于这个目标——也就是修复友谊——也是很重要的，因为这无关乎争胜负。这关乎恢复心理安全感。这关乎恢复信任。当你不愿意承认自己的角色，哪怕只是很小的一部分时，我认为这发出了防御性的信号。并且我认为，我也知道，研究向我们表明，防御性是会立即激活对方威胁反应的东西。
They're immediately going to go on the defensiveness, like the defensive. They're going to feel unheard, invalidated. They're going to become more entrenched in their own position because that's where, where they feel safest. Again, this is closely tied to our ego defense mechanisms. We want to protect ourselves. We don't want to feel like we are a bad person. But it also shows that we're probably going in with some cognitive dissonance, where we're resisting some information that challenges our sense of being the good one,
他们会立即进入防御状态。他们会感到没有被倾听、被否定。他们会更根深蒂固地坚守自己的立场，因为那是他们感觉最安全的地方。同样，这与我们的自我防御机制紧密相连。我们要保护自己。我们不想觉得自己是个坏人。但这同时也表明，我们可能带着某种认知失调入场，我们在抵制某些挑战我们“自己是好人”这一认知的的信息，
information or facts that may actually be there. And I think beyond that, just by humbling, yourself. You allow yourself to be more present and you allow yourself to have more empathy for them. You lower the emotional stakes, you model accountability, and researchers have also seen that it creates what we call a reciprocity of vulnerability. Basically, when one person softens and one person says, I'm sorry for this, sets the emotional tone of openness, says I'm willing to learn, the other person is far more likely to follow, so it's a lot more fruitful. I just think that it makes it, it just shifts the dynamic and the tone from adversarial
那些可能确实存在的信息或事实。我认为除此之外，只要放低姿态。你让自己能够更加专注，你也让自己对他们有更多的同理心。你降低了情感赌注，你树立了责任感的榜样，研究人员还发现，它创造了我们所谓的“脆弱性的互惠”。基本上，当一个人态度软化，一个人说“我为这件事道歉”，就奠定了开放的情感基调，表示“我愿意学习”，另一个人就更有可能效仿，所以效果会富有成效得多。我只是觉得这使得，它只是将动态和基调从对抗性转变为
to collaborative. And guess what? Even if the other person doesn't do this as well, even if this person is unwilling to humble themselves, it's still effective and it still means that you get to walk out with more clarity because you'll be able to say, like, I stepped into their shoes, I got the birds eye view, I was willing to take account of this part of my job is done. The next step for repairing a friendship is probably the hardest one, but somebody needs to reach out first, right? Or if you're still in that awkward state of like, we both know something's wrong, but neither of us really wants to touch it. If you're in that situation, one of you needs to initiate that like we need to talk protocol. And I think it should
走向协作。你猜怎么着？即便对方做不到这一点，即便这个人不愿意放低姿态，这依然是奏效的，这意味着你仍然能带着更多的清晰感离开，因为你会觉得，我设身处地为他们着想了，我掌握了全局，我愿意承担这部分工作，我已经做到了。修复友谊的下一步可能是最难的一步，但总得有人先伸出援手，对吧？或者，如果你还处于那种尴尬的状态，就是：我们都知道出了问题，但谁也不想去触碰它。如果你正处于那种境地，你们中必须得有人来启动“我们需要谈谈”的流程。而我觉得这个人应该
be you. And I can totally, I feel like I can sense that you rolled your eyes, you grown, you took a deep breath. I know it sucks, but I think you know I'm right as well. You're the one who's listening to this. You're the one who knows something's wrong. You're the one who has the intention of repairing the friendship. So you're going to have to be the bigger person. I'm going to talk you through exactly what you're going to say, what you're going to send. Don't worry. You won't be alone. But it has to be you. When you go to send the text, because I think it's worth preparing somebody that you want to have the conversation rather than just being like, boo, we're going to talk about it. Firstly, don't send the message late at night and don't send it from a place of hostility. I had a
是你。我完全能感觉到，我甚至能感觉到你翻了个白眼，你叹了口气，你深吸了一口气。我知道这很糟糕，但我想你也知道我是对的。听播客的是你。知道出问题的是你。怀着修复这段友谊意愿的也是你。所以，你得表现得成熟大度一些。我会一步步指导你接下来该说些什么，发些什么。别担心。你不会孤单的。但必须是你。当你准备发送短信时——因为我觉得最好先给对方打个预防针，说明你想聊聊，而不是直接突袭说：“嘿，我们得谈谈。”首先，不要在深夜发信息，也不要带着敌意去发。我
friendship broke up when I was like 20, where a friend of mine texted me probably one of the meanest messages I have ever received in my life at like 2 a.m. in the morning, essentially being like, we need to figure this out. But by the way, you're in the wrong. That was the day of my grandfather's funeral. 2 a.m. the day of my grandfather's funeral. He sent me that message. Any hope of us repairing that friendship was like gone in that second. I knew I had serious things to apologize for. I knew that I'd messed up, but I was just like, this is so emotionally unsettling. And it's so clear to me that you don't, like, you just want to yell at me. And there's not going to be any collaboration here that it was just like that's it's it's done if your intentions are to get somewhere
在大概20岁时经历过一次绝交，当时我的一位朋友在凌晨两点左右给我发了一条我这辈子收到的最恶毒的信息之一，大意是：我们得把这事弄清楚。但顺便说一句，是你的错。那正好是我爷爷的葬礼那天。凌晨两点，我爷爷葬礼的那天。他给我发了这条消息。我们修复那段友谊的任何希望在那一秒钟就破灭了。我知道我有严重的事情需要道歉。我知道我搞砸了，但我当时就觉得：这实在太让人情绪崩溃了。而且我很清楚，你根本不是来沟通的，你只是想对我大吼大叫。这里绝不会有什么协作可言，当时的感觉就是：行吧，就这样吧，彻底结束了。如果你的目的是想通过这件事
from this 5 p.m. 6 p.m. after work they have time to sit with it state your intentions clearly over text so like do you want to apologize do you want to talk do you want to figure out what happened do you want to find a way through highlight the situation you are talking about like and tell your friend what the ideal outcome is in your text message remember in this episode. Remember in this episode, we are talking about how to repair a friendship. This is like the best way you can go about it to get that outcome. This is like a make-your-own-adventure text message, right? But you can use this structure for everything. You know, I'll give an example. Like, there's a difference between I want to talk about what happened at the wedding, intention, so that we can be amicable for the next
在下午5点、6点下班后，他们有时间去消化这件事的时候，通过短信清晰地陈述你的意图。比如：你想道歉吗？你想聊聊吗？你想弄清楚发生了什么吗？你想找到一个解决的办法吗？指出你正在讨论的具体情况，并在短信中告诉你的朋友你理想的结局是什么。记住，在本期节目中。记住在本期节目中，我们正在讨论如何修复友谊。这是你为了达成该结果所能采取的最佳方式。这就像是一条“自主选择结局”的短信，对吧？但你可以把这种结构应用到任何事情上。你知道的，我举个例子。比如，这有区别：“我想聊聊婚礼上发生的事情（意图），这样我们在下一场
wedding outcome and talk. Like, intention, action, outcome. So, that we can be amicable for the next wedding outcome. And talk. like intention, action, outcome versus something like, I want to apologize for what I said to our mutual friend because I think that we can get through this. Again, intention, outcome, action. And then like another one, just for fun. Like, I felt hurt by your actions a few weeks back. I want to clear the air so that we can reach a mutual understanding and move forward. Like that structure works always.
婚礼上还能和睦相处（结局）并且聊聊。”也就是：意图、行动、结局。对比一下：“我想为我对共同朋友说的话道歉，因为我认为我们能度过难关。”再次强调：意图、结局、行动。然后，再来一个，纯属好玩。比如：“几周前你的行为让我感到受伤。我想把话说开，以便我们能达成共识并继续前进。”这种结构永远适用。
I think it probably would even work for a real breakup, but that's for another time. I think it's really scary to be the one to acknowledge that there's a problem. But by saying it out loud, I think you're one step closer to being able to just move on. There's this amazing book by Claire Cohen called The Truth About Female Friendship. And great book, by the way, but she talks a lot in her book about how until somebody takes that first step, the situation, only exists in each other's heads. And when it sits in your head, it's mutated over and over again by you replaying and you adding assumptions and you having conversations with other people. And it's adding all these ingredients in until it becomes this like a nuclear version of what it once was.
我想它甚至可能适用于真正的分手，但这以后有机会再聊。承认有问题存在，这本身真的非常吓人。但只要把它说出口，我觉得你就离释怀更近了一步。克莱尔·科恩（Claire Cohen）写过一本非常棒的书，叫《女性友谊的真相》（The Truth About Female Friendship）。顺便说一句，这是一本好书，但她在书中深入探讨了一个观点：在有人迈出第一步之前，那种情况仅仅存在于彼此的脑海中。当它停留在你的脑海里时，会经过你一遍又一遍的反复回想、不断脑补各种假设、以及与其他人谈论，从而不断发生变异。它不断加入各种调料，直到变成这件事情曾经面貌的“核爆升级版”。
Like keeping it inside is like keeping it in like a toxic incubator until the conflict ends up representing something that it never was to begin with. The easiest way to kill this kind of of beast and to stop this from developing, it's just like to straight up be like, let's just freaking tear it open and talk about it. Even if it turns out nothing will change their mind, even if they don't want to talk to you, that is still closure in its own form. As I just mentioned, like there is that alternative. That alternative and that outcome is always possible. They may say no. They might ghost you. And at that stage, As much as I said, fight for your friends, just leave it.
把事情憋在心里，就像把它放在一个有毒的孵化器里，直到冲突最终演变成它最初根本不具备的样子。消灭这种“怪兽”、阻止事态恶化的最简单方法，就是直截了当地说：“咱们直接把它撕开谈谈吧。”哪怕结果证明没有任何事能改变他们的想法，哪怕他们根本不想跟你说话，那也算是一种形式的句号。正如我刚才所提到的，确实存在那种替代可能。这种替代可能和结局永远都是存在的。他们可能会拒绝。他们可能会对你冷暴力。而在那个阶段，尽管我说过要为朋友而战，但此时就随它去吧。
Like, you did what you thought was right and best for you. They're going to do the same thing. It goes without saying that, you know, you shouldn't force the other person to engage with you if they don't want to. And trust me, I get it. I understand just how hurtful it can be for you to, like, really put your heart on the line and to be, like, really vulnerable in reaching out in the first place and for them to just be like, no. Like, it hurts. It's basically a form of social rejection, but so much more like vulnerable.
就像，你做了你认为正确且对你最好的事。他们也会做同样的事。不言而喻的是，你知道的，如果对方不愿意互动，你就不应该强迫他们。相信我，我懂。我完全理解当你真正敞开心扉、冒着极大的脆弱感去迈出第一步，而他们却冷冷地回一句“不”时，会有多受伤。这种感觉很痛。这基本上算是一种社交拒绝，但却带有更多赤裸裸的脆弱感。
But I still think that's an answer. Like, I know it's probably harder than if you had had the conversation because there's this ambiguous loss. And it's obvious they have some very strong opinions that they'll, that you'll never hear and they'll never share with you. And that means that you have to close the story. but sometimes that's just life, right? That's a lesson in other ways.
但我依然认为这是一个答案。我知道这可能比你们真正聊过要难受，因为这是一种模棱两可的失落感。很明显，他们有一些非常坚定的看法，是你永远也听不到、他们也永远不会跟你分享的。这意味着你必须为这个故事画上句号。但有时生活就是这样，对吧？这也是换一种方式的上了一课。
That's a lesson not in humility but in acceptance. And that's just the risk of ever being close to anybody. Sometimes they don't see the importance of fighting for friendship. Sometimes they don't see the importance of repairing. Sometimes you have done things that you don't realize were immensely hurt, like harmful that they don't want to talk about. And that's just the way things are. don't go digging, don't go pushing.
这不是关于谦逊的一课，而是关于接受的一课。这就是与任何人亲近所必然要承担的风险。有时他们看不到为友谊而战的重要性。有时他们看不到修复关系的重要性。有时你做了自己并未意识到极其具有伤害性的事，而他们根本不想谈论。事情就是这样。不要去深挖，不要去逼迫。
There is, there is, again, a lesson in creating our own closure. I actually found it helpful. I went through a situation like this where I was like, I really have probably screwed up. I want to talk about it. I also didn't really know what had happened. And she didn't want to talk to me. And I made this list because I was like obsessing over it. And I made this huge list of like everything I loved about this person.
再次强调，这里面也有关于如何为自己画上句号的一课。我其实觉得这很有帮助。我曾经历过这样一种情况：当时我觉得“我可能真的搞砸了，我想谈谈”。同时我也确实不知道究竟发生了什么。而她不想跟我说话。我列了张清单，因为我当时一直在钻牛角尖。我列了一大串我喜欢这个人的地方。
Everything I wanted you like everything I wanted for. her, how happy I wanted to see her. And I also just kept saying, like, this is the only way it could have gone. The role we played in each other's lives is over, but the role we played was important, nonetheless. It just had to be this way. This is just the state of our friendship. And I actually saw her walking in London recently, walking down my street in a different country with her partner, and I was a bit of a coward. I crossed the road. But I kind of looked back at her, just like, I don't We never got the closure, but she looked really happy and she just seemed really happy. And maybe if we tried to fix things at that time and if she had reached out and accepted my,
我想要为她好的一切，我希望看到她有多快乐。同时我也一直对自己说：“事情只能这样发展了。我们在彼此生命中扮演的角色已经结束了，但我们曾经扮演的角色依然至关重要。事情只能如此。这就是我们友谊的现状。”不久前，我实际上在伦敦看到过她，在另一个国家，她和伴侣走在我常走的街上。而我当时有点当了缩头乌龟，我过马路躲开了。但我回头看了看她，心里想：我们虽然从来没有得到过一个正式的句号，但她看起来真的很开心，她显得非常快乐。也许如果我们当时试图去修复关系，如果她当时伸出手接受了我的
like, want my desire to like talk about it, we wouldn't be in the situations we were now where we were happier, not as friends. Like, I just feel like that made sense to me in that moment that like the future that we needed meant that we couldn't be friends anymore and look at us both in these futures, very, very happy and that was worth more to me than the closure conversation and figuring out what went wrong and why and rehashing details. Not to say that's every situation, but I think sometimes that is the situation and now me having the hindsight of being through that situation and like six years later being like, wow, just like a breakup, it all works out the way it should be like is just something
意愿——那种想要沟通的渴望，我们就不会落得今天这种“虽然不再是朋友，但各自过得更快乐”的境地。我觉得那一刻我终于想通了：我们所需要的未来意味着我们不能再做朋友了，看看我们俩在各自的未来里，都过得非常非常快乐，这比非要一个收尾的对话、非要弄清楚哪里出了问题以及为什么、非要去重新咀嚼那些细节，要有价值得多。并不是说所有情况都如此，但我认为有时情况确实如此。现在，当我带着“经历过这一切”的后见之明，在六年后的今天回看，觉得“就像分手一样，一切都会按它该有的样子发展”，这正是我
I kind of want to, I don't know, impart on you, I guess. But back to the chat, back to how we're going to approach when somebody says, yes, I think we do need to discuss rather than the worst case scenario of nothing, prepare for the awkwardness and prepare to possibly feel deeply misunderstood. You're coming to this, like, the reason you're in this situation is because somebody was misunderstood and things were confusing. And that's going to be like ripping off a band-aid. Like it's going to be deeply uncomfortable and then you're going to find such relief that it's
某种程度上想要传达给你的，我想是的。不过回到正题，回到我们该如何应对“当有人说‘好，我想我们确实需要讨论一下’而不是毫无回应的最坏情况”时，你要做好面对尴尬的准备，并做好可能会深深感到被误解的心理准备。你之所以走到这一步，你之所以陷入这种境地，正是因为有人被误解了，事情变得扑朔迷离。这就好比撕掉一块创可贴。过程会极其难受，但随后你会感到如释重负，因为
just the ambiguity is slowly disappearing. I also want you to trust that you're an adult, they're an adult. they're an adult, you can handle conflict. You can handle being uncomfortable. And in part, friction is an important, is a necessity for growth and becoming a better person. Seeing the friend in person as well will also help you with this. Remembering that they are flesh and blood, remembering that they deserve empathy is so much more valuable than like having an argument over text or even over the phone. It's harder. It's worth it. And Just give yourself a lot of time.
这种模棱两可的感觉正在慢慢消失。我也希望你相信：你是个成年人，他们也是成年人。他们是成年人，你也能应对冲突。你能够承受不适。从某种意义上说，摩擦是成长和成为更好之人的必然需要。当面见到这位朋友也会对你有所帮助。记住他们是有血有肉的人，记住他们值得拥有同理心，这比通过短信甚至电话来争论要有价值得多。这更难。但这很值得。而且给自己留出充足的时间。
Like if you're going to have this conversation, prepare to feel awkward. Also prepare like a couple of hours. Like prepare a couple hours to really hash things out. And I think if you give yourself that space, I don't know anybody who has ever regretted having a conversation like this with a friend, even if it was awkward to begin with, even if the outcome was less than ideal. Because I think putting yourself in what is going to be an awkward situation, firstly gives you answers.
如果你打算进行这次谈话，请做好感到尴尬的心理准备。同时也要腾出几个小时的时间。比如准备好两小时来彻底把事情掰扯清楚。我想如果你给自己留出了这个空间，我从没听说过有谁曾后悔与朋友进行过这样的谈话，哪怕一开始很尴尬，哪怕结果不那么理想。因为我认为让自己置身于将要面对的尴尬境地中，首先能给你答案。
secondly probably will repair your friendship and it's also just really self-affirming in a way even if it doesn't go right. I don't know if this makes sense but I think being willing to put yourself in uncomfortable situations proves that you are a person that fights for your friends, proves that you are somebody who endures uncomfortable things for those they love, proves that you are honest, proves that you can embrace raw human emotion and that you are the person that you say you are. Like again, even if it doesn't go your way, even if it makes you really anxious, you can always leave that situation being like, at least I tried, at least I fought, and here is proof that I live out my values. I say I'm a good person. I say I'm somebody who has
其次很可能会修复你们的友谊，而且从某种程度上讲，即使事情没有往好的方向发展，这也非常能够自我肯定。我不知道这讲不讲得通，但我认为愿意让自己处于不舒服的境地，证明了你是一个为朋友而战的人，证明了你是一个为了所爱之人能够忍受不适的人，证明了你很诚实，证明了你能够拥抱赤裸的人类情感，证明了你就是你所说的那种人。再次强调，即使事情没有如你所愿，即使它让你感到非常焦虑，你离开时也总是可以这样想：至少我尝试过了，至少我抗争过了，这就是我践行自己价值观的证明。我说过我是一个好人。我说过我是一个敢于进行
hard conversations. I say I'm a good friend. Here is the evidence. Like, I endured this discomfort. I did the thing that was not the easiest thing for somebody that I cared about. And that in itself is, I think, I don't know, I think just good for our self-esteem and good for our future capacity as a friend. Okay, let's take one more short break here before we talk about a few other things that you can prepare for. And what happens after the hard conversation is over. Stay with us. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart.
艰难对话的人。我说过我是一个好朋友。这就是证据。我忍受了这种不适。为了一个我关心的人，我做了那件并非最轻松的事。我认为这本身，怎么说呢，对我们的自尊以及未来作为朋友的包容力都大有裨益。好了，在我们讨论其他几个你可以做好准备的事情，以及艰难对话结束之后会发生什么之前，我们先在这里休息一小会儿。不要走开。骄傲就像爱。你在心中能感受到它。
IR Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must-have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists, like back-in-the-day pride. Come together, celebrate, love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHartP Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone.
IR Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用，包含 iHeart Pride Canada、你最爱的热门金曲和必备派对嗨曲，还有个性化及精选播放列表，比如“旧日风情骄傲季”。欢聚一堂，庆祝，爱。随时随地，将骄傲带在身边。只需让你的智能音箱播放 iHeart Pride Canada。在手机上收听我们。
Listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case?
立即登录 iHeartRadio.ca 收听。当时，感觉这一幕仿佛永远不会结束。我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。那双眼睛里面空洞无物。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓了个半死。那是你的第一起谋杀案？
Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo.
是的，长官。可以毫不夸张地说，这是你职业生涯中最大的案子吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸谋杀案。这是最糟糕的恶性案件了。我想是的。各位，清醒点吧。我才是那个亲眼目睹克雷韦特和德皮波行凶过程的人。
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world.
安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说我没有杀人。我要把这冤屈带进棺材里。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。要想无广告收听《恶魔采石场》并享受独家内容，请在苹果播客上订阅 Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby），播客《霍达·科特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby）的主持人。接下来，我们将与世界上最迷人的人展开有意义的对话。
most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer. And that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez.
比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何战胜严峻的健康挑战。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌。而后者更加艰难。有很多人理解产后抑郁。但我对产后焦虑却毫无准备。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。这让人无比兴奋，因为他们的全新明星是哈维尔·T·托里托·埃尔南德斯（Javier T. Torito Hernandez）。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist?
每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我依然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，从我出生起就是如此。我仍然有太多的疑问。我们从哪里来？人死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消资格？C罗还是梅西？真的有外星人吗？
What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends where vulnerability comes out conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just.
什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常平凡到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、纯粹的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感得以释放，阴谋论被摆上台面，人生目标和经验教训得以分享。生命中的一切都有着完美的秩序，一切皆是公正。
Wait me, I'm going to pressuram and me will go to be able to be connected. The Chicharito. And Javier Tchartreli. And together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, stay close. It is a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human or IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
等等我，我要去普拉苏拉姆（pressuram），我和他将会建立连接。我是小豌豆（The Chicharito）。我是哈维尔·查特雷利（Javier Tchartreli）。我们将与 iHeart Radio 一起，将平凡化为非凡，敬请期待。这太棒了。哇。在 iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to be Human）。
Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong on what that might look like. No, I didn't want to manifest that.
基思·詹曼卡（Keith Gianmanca）看起来像个温文尔雅的郊区老爸，但暗地里，他变成了另一个人——一个变装大师，开启了一场犯罪狂欢。当时，这听起来像是个疯狂的主意吗？这听起来非常疯狂，但我当时走投无路，觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你有没有让自己去思考，事情可能会如何搞砸，那会是什么样子。不，我不想去预示那种结果。
I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue.
我试图去预示成功。每个家庭都有自己的秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。这永远改变了我的生活和我家的家庭动态，因为我现实中先前存在的一切现在都成了谎言。
Listen to deep cover, The Family Man, on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When it comes to having hard conversations with people you love about situations you really don't love, one of the best pieces of advice I've ever received came from a mentor I had at my corporate job who told me, in any conflict situation, prepare to be more silent than you'd like to be. basically let the other person speak. This is a time for listening, not debating. And I think about that at least once a week.
在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听深度报道播客《深层卧底：顾家男人》（Deep Cover: The Family Man）。当需要与你所爱的人、就那些你实在不喜欢的状况进行艰难的对话时，我收到的最好建议之一来自于我曾在公司工作时的一位导师，他告诉我：在任何冲突情况下，准备好比你想要的那样更加沉默。基本上就是让对方说话。这是倾听的时候，而不是辩论的时候。我每周至少会想起这句话一次。
I always think about that phrase that's like, we have two ears and one mouth. Like try to use that ratio when you are having a tough conversation. I think the reason this is such a valuable rule is not because you shouldn't say what you want to say and is not because you don't have a right to speak up, but it just goes directly against your brain's instinct in moments of social tension
我总是想起那句名言，大意是：我们长了两只耳朵却只有一张嘴。在进行艰难的对话时，试着运用这个比例。我认为这条规则之所以如此宝贵，并不是因为你不该说出你想说的话，也不是因为你没有权利发声，而是因为它直接违背了大脑在社交紧张时刻的本能反应。
to just jump in there, defend, be loud, say your peace. When a conversation feels threatening, your nervous system shifts into basically a mild version of fight or flight. You're not just talking, like you are subconsciously trying to protect yourself because you feel like you're kind of in danger, and that's when people end up saying, doing, communicating things in ways they don't want to. So it's not about speaking less, it's about giving yourself space to say what you actually want to say. They over-explained, they interrupt, they defend, you are going to miss what's actually being said underneath.
那就是马上插话、辩护、提高嗓门、表明立场。当谈话让人感到具有威胁性时，你的神经系统基本上会切换到“战斗或逃跑”的轻度模式。你不仅仅是在说话——你是在潜意识里试图保护自己，因为你觉得自己好像处于某种危险之中，而这正是人们最终以自己不希望的方式说出、做出或沟通事情的时候。所以这并不是要少说话，而是要给自己留出空间去说出你真正想说的话。如果他们过度解释、打断谈话、进行辩护，你就会错过真正隐藏在底下的言外之意。
All your hearing is what you want to hear. You're not listening to their explanation. You're not listening to their point of view. you're not listening to their words or their motivations, you're just listening to the context and what you think applies to your feelings. There is also a concept in psychology called reactance. This is our human tendency to push back harder when we feel like someone is trying to persuade or correct us or trying to force us into something we don't want to or we don't want to do or, you know, force us into an apology, force us into a perspective.
你听到的只有你想听的。你没有在听他们的解释。你没有在听他们的观点。你没有听他们的话语或动机，你只是在听上下文以及你认为适用于你感受的东西。心理学上还有一个概念叫做“抗拒”（Reactance）。这是我们人类的一种倾向：当感觉有人试图说服、纠正我们，或者试图强迫我们做不想做的事，或者不想做的事时（你知道的，强迫我们道歉，强迫我们接受某种观点），我们会进行更强烈的回击。
And they've done studies on this that reveal that when people do feel like they're forced to apologize or show empathy before they truly have enough information or they've said what they want to say, it just creates more tension and conflict down the line. Obviously stand up for yourself. Obviously be truthful. Turn over the stones that you want to turn over. But if you're feeling overwhelmed by what this is going to bring up, remember you can always just be silent whilst you process.
人们对此做过研究，结果显示：当人们觉得自己被强迫道歉、或在真正掌握足够信息或说出想说的话之前就被强迫表现出同情时，这只会日后引发更多的紧张和冲突。当然要为自己挺身而出。当然要讲实话。去翻开你想翻开的石头。但如果你觉得这件事引发的情绪让你不知所措，请记住，在处理情绪时，你随时可以选择保持沉默。
Like you don't immediately have to say something in response to whatever it is they choose to say. And it's not a game, obviously, it's not a tip for tap competition. But I think it will probably give you an advantage in many ways, at least in terms of emotional control. Part of repairing a friendship is also knowing that you don't have to accept the first apology. And then again, it's not advantage. for the future of your friendship, if you just sweep things under the rug and just take whatever, the first thing that comes to you is a way to placate your feelings and then you move forward. You may have to come back to this a few times. You're allowed to say, I don't accept
对于他们选择说的任何话，你不必立即做出回应。这显然不是一场游戏，也不是一场针锋但我认为这在很多方面都会给你带来优势，至少在情绪控制方面是这样。修复友谊的一部分，也包括懂得你不必接受第一次道歉。再说一次，如果你只是把事情扫到地毯底下，随便接受了任何首先出现的东西来安抚你的情绪，然后就继续往前走，这对你友谊的未来没有任何好处。你可能需要为此反复沟通好几次。你可以说：“我接受不了
your apology, but I still want to work it out, or I still don't see it that way, or I still don't know if you see things from my perspective, instead of just thank you or I'm sorry to. I just think this is such, like, practical advice, be silent, don't accept the first apology if you don't want to. It takes so much vulnerability and strength to come to the table and to outwardly admit things are damaged and things are not what they should be. It also takes a lot of courage to say, I want to fix them. And you're already in this uncomfortable space. Like, you did the hardest thing of all, which was to enter the conversation. So push on. Stay in the space until you get what you need or you both sincerely feel better about the situation. I feel like I personally see this a lot.
你的道歉，但我仍然想解决它”或者“我仍然不那样看，或者我仍然不知道你是否从我的角度看问题”，而不是只说一句“谢谢”或“我也很抱歉”。我只是觉得这真的是非常实用的建议：保持沉默，如果你不想的话，就不要接受第一次道歉。带着问题来到台面上，并公开承认事情已经破裂、事情不如预期，这需要巨大的脆弱感和力量。说出“我想修复它们”也需要很大的勇气。你已经身处这个让人不舒服的空间了。你完成了最难的一件事，那就是开启了对话。所以，坚持下去。留在这个空间里，直到你得到你需要的东西，或者你们两个人都真诚地对现状感到释怀。我觉得我个人经常看到这种情况。
People have the hard chat or the confrontation and an apology is given or an excuse is given because and it's just so awkward. They're like, let's just get it over with. And there's no actual depth of understanding. And I think there's nothing worse than coming out of one of these conversations, having done the hard thing, telling everyone like, yeah, we're all good. are back to normal and then hearing later on that like they're still angry or there's still a problem. So like communicate, communicate, communicate. Keep pushing. Keep uncovering if you feel like there is things left unstead. You know, you may as well. Like you're here now. Like you've done the hard thing. I also think checking at the end with what the other person is feeling. For instance, like again,
人们进行了艰难的交谈或对峙，对方给出了道歉或借口，因为——这实在太尴尬了。他们会说：“赶紧把这事了结吧。”而没有任何真正的理解深度。我认为没有什么比从这样一场对话中走出来更糟糕的了：你做了难做的事，告诉每个人“是的，我们都挺好的，一切恢复正常了”，结果后来却听说他们其实还在生气，或者问题依然存在。所以，沟通，沟通，沟通。继续推进。如果你觉得还有没解决的事情，继续去揭开它。你知道的，反正你也豁出去了。你现在就在这里。你已经完成了最难的部分。我还认为，要在最后核对一下另一个人的感受。例如，再次强调，
you don't want that discrepancy. Like you don't want there to be them to walk away. and be like, we're totally fine and you're like, no, we're not. Or them to walk away and be like, they blamed me for everything and you'd be like, oh, I really see their perspective. Like, really have a clear idea of what each other's point of view is and what you want to change and what they want to change. If the other person wants to go away and think about some of the things they've said, then come back to you, you need to respect that too. You might need to do that as well. Like, you might feel a little bit confused. Obviously, I know I said, like, keep, like, like you may have to come back or that you should keep pushing the conversation, but it's also
你不希望出现这种落差。你绝对不希望他们离开时觉得“我们完全没事”，而你却觉得“不，我们根本不好”。或者他们离开时觉得“这人把所有责任都推给我了”，而你却觉得“我真的理解他们的观点”。一定要对彼此的观点、你想改变的地方以及他们想改变的地方有一个清晰的了解。如果对方想离开并思考一下他们说过的一些话，然后再来找你，你也需要尊重这一点。你可能也需要这样做。比如，你可能会感到有点困惑。当然，我知道我刚才说过“继续推进”——比如你可能需要回来继续，或者你应该继续推动对话，但同样也是
fair to be like, no, I need more time to think about it. What I'm really saying is like, don't just get to this point and be like, cool, we've done it. We've done the hard thing. We've done the situation. We've talked. Let's move on. And like you're still hurt or they're still hurt. Like don't, again, I think what this is what it all comes down to. The easiest situation is often, no. the best situation for the longevity of your friendship. So if it's not fine, if you are still struggling, if they clearly haven't moved on, like, it's okay to come back. I also think in the days after you have a conversation, you're going to feel a little bit
合理的做法是说：“不，我需要更多时间来考虑一下。”我真正想说的是：不要只是走到这一步就觉得“太好了，我们做到了。我们完成了艰难的部分。我们经历了这情况。我们聊过了。我们继续往前走吧”，而实际上你心里或他们心里仍然受着伤。不要——再次强调，我认为归根结底就是这样。最简单的局面往往并非——对友谊的长期发展来说最好的局面。所以如果事情并没有变好，如果你仍在苦苦挣扎，如果他们明显还没有释怀，那么，回来重新谈谈是没问题的。我还认为，在进行对话后的几天里，你可能会觉得内心有些
raw. Things may have been said that you're like, oh, like, I really had to like confront some things about myself. just take some time to breathe. Like, you don't have to text them straight afterwards. You don't have to, like, immediately jump back into how you were before. But definitely, like, leave the door open. And definitely, like, if you said that you'd reach out and you would make plans, do it.
隐隐作痛。有些话可能已经说出口，让你觉得：“哦，天哪，我真的不得不直面自己的一些问题。”只需花点时间呼吸。你不需要在事后立即给他们发信息。你不需要立刻恢复到以前的状态。但绝对要把大门敞开。而且如果你说过你会主动联系并制定计划，那就去做吧。
If they asked for changes to behavior or they asked for you to tell them what you needed, tell them, show them. If you still have more thoughts, obviously, tell them. again, this is the final snag for our friendship full outs. We get so far, so far, so far we jump over all the hurdles, we jump over other people's opinions, we jump over how freaking awkward it is sometimes to just like talk about things that sting our ego
如果他们要求改变行为，或者要求你告诉他们你需要什么，那就告诉他们，向他们展示。如果你还有更多想法，当然，也要告诉他们。再次强调，这是我们友谊破裂后的最后一个难关。我们走了这么远，越过了所有的栏杆，越过了别人的看法，越过了那种有时仅仅为了谈论刺痛我们自尊的事情而感到无比尴尬的情绪，
and then here the ego comes in again and swoops in at the last moment and like prevents us from actually changing anything or decides that it's too hard. So I think when you get to that point, really be like, okay, if it keeps going this way, Like, am I going to be happy if it just goes back to what it was before? Like, what actually needs to change? Because you don't want to be here again in six months' time having the same conversation.
然后，自尊心又在这个时候卷土重来，在最后一刻介入，阻止我们真正去改变任何事情，或者让我们觉得太难了。所以我想，当你到了那个地步时，真的要问问自己：“好吧，如果事情继续这样发展，如果它只是回到以前的样子，我会快乐吗？到底什么才需要改变？”因为你绝对不想在六个月后又回到这里进行同样的对话。
Or you don't want to have had this conversation for nothing because neither of the things that either of you said actually got through. And you know what? I think 90% of the time, I think it's fine. Like, I do think it does get better without needing the follow up. And most people are susceptible to change. and most people, you included, probably just need a 20-minute chat to clear the air. I also think for long-term friendships, like eventually these conversations become funny or they become sentimental. You know, they become iconic in a weird way, like the fight that nearly ended things,
或者你也不希望这次对话白费，因为你们双方所说的任何话根本都没有听进去。你知道吗？我认为90%的情况下，事情其实都是没问题的。我是说，我确实觉得不需要后续跟进，情况也会变好。大多数人都是能够接受改变的，而且大多数人——包括你在内——可能只需要20分钟的闲聊就能把话说开。我还认为对于长期的友谊来说，最终这些对话会变成笑谈，或者变得充满感伤。你知道的，它们会以一种奇特的方式变得具有标志性，比如那场险些毁掉一切的争吵，
the disagreement that felt significant at the time, and we made it through. And in many cases, that is a bonding thing. Like, I wish we saw fighting with our friends as a bonding, exercise. Even when you're arguing, even when you're disagreeing, it's still a valuable shared experience. And that's like the whole basis of friendship anyways. A hill I will die on is that you don't truly know your friend until you've had a fight with them and you've gotten through it. It's like the thing that opens up like a whole new depth of like communication and shared values and resilience. And like, it's going to sound corny. Like love. It makes you love your friends more. Obviously, you love each other. Like, you both collectively wanted to make it through this.
那个在当时看来意义重大、而我们最终挺过来了的分歧。在许多情况下，这成了一种凝聚力的纽带。真的，我希望我们能把和朋友吵架看作是一种增进感情的练习。即使你们在争论，即使你们在意见不一，那依然是一段宝贵的共同经历。而这本来就是友谊的全部基础。我坚信的一个观点是：除非你和朋友吵过一架并且挺了过来，否则你就不算真正了解你的朋友。这就像是打开了一扇通往全新深度的窗户，里面充满了沟通、共同的价值观和韧性。而且，听起来可能有点老套。就像爱一样。它会让你更爱你的朋友。显然，你们彼此相爱。你们双方都共同渴望度过难关。
And that's like really reaffirming because you don't do that for every friendship. Some people don't even do that for like relationships they've been in for years. And I think that is a sign of dedication. And I think if you guys are able to make it through this, you're going to look back and both of you are going to be like, wow, that person really loves me. And I also think it says his precedent where a lot of friendships operate on this like, are you mad at me? Are you not mad at me? And they never actually ask. And there's a lot of anxiety and tension in that. You guys won't have that again. Like you will have the freedom now having done this, having practiced this. So that like meaning that any future conflict or disagreement or miscommunication will be handled
这真的非常具有肯定意义，因为你不会为每一段友谊都这样做。有些人甚至不会为他们维持了多年的恋爱关系这样做。我认为这是一个全身心投入的标志。我想如果你们能够挺过这一关，回首往事时，你们两个都会感叹：“哇，那个人是真的爱我。”我也认为这树立了一个先例：很多友谊的运作方式是——“你生我气了吗？你没生我气吧？”但他们从不真正去问。这其中包含着大量的焦虑和紧张。你们以后就不会这样了。你们现在拥有了自由，因为经历过这一切，实践过这一切。这意味着未来任何的冲突、分歧或沟通不畅都将得到
in like a similar way and will be handled like appropriately because now you have the blueprint for like how you're going to go about these conversations. So I think that's really like the beginnings of how you repair a friendship. Obviously, I can't talk to your specific situation about like what maybe does need to change in your friendship. But I think if you leave a conversation like this being like, this is what needs to change, you're both clear on it. And you kind of have a check in either individually or collectively like a couple months down the line. Or you can kind of do that on your own and be like, yeah, everything's good or everything's bad, but I kind of gave it a change. or I want to give it another chance, like you are on the right path.
妥善处理，就像采用类似的方式一样，因为你们现在有了处理这些对话的蓝图。所以我认为这真的只是修复友谊的开端。当然，我无法针对你的具体情况去谈论你的友谊中可能需要改变什么。但我想如果你结束这样一场对话时能够觉得：“这就是需要改变的地方”，你们双方都对此很清楚，并且在几个月后无论是通过个人还是集体的方式进行一次回访，或者你自己默默去复盘，觉得“是的，一切都很好”或者“一切都很糟，但我至少尝试去改变了，或者我想再给它一次机会”，那么你就走在了正确的道路上。
Like I said, obviously just speaking from personal experience and other people's experience as well, because I don't know, sometimes I don't fully know if my experience is everybody's, but I think 90% of the time a friendship is not destroyed by a hard conversation. A friendship is actually strengthened by a hard conversation. And like I just said, you are doing a service to this other person. you are doing a service to the strength of your bond by saying that wasn't okay, I'm not okay, this whole situation isn't okay, and I love you enough that I want to say something. And I love you enough that I want to be honest with you and you be honest with me and we're going
正如我所说，这显然只是代表我个人的经验以及其他人的经验，因为，怎么说呢，有时我并不完全确定我的经验是否适用于所有人，但我认为90%的情况下，友谊不会被一次艰难的对话所摧毁。相反，友谊实际上会因为一次艰难的对话而变得更加牢固。就像我刚才所说的那样，你在对另一个人尽一份力。你通过说“这不对劲，我感觉不好，整个情况都不对劲，而且我足够爱你，所以我想说出来。我足够爱你，所以想对你诚实，你也对我诚实，我们一定会”来巩固你们纽带的力量。
to work through it. And I think that intention and that motivation is like the biggest indicator that the friendship that you have with this person is worth repairing, especially when it's reciprocated. So I think that's all I have time for when it comes to this episode. I will say I'm going through kind of a situation like this at the moment and I need to take my own advice. I think half the reason why I made this episode was because I just kind of need to, I don't know, I need to warm up.
“一起解决它。”我认为这种意图和动机，是证明你与这个人之间的友谊值得修复的最大指标，尤其是当这种意图得到回应的时候。好了，关于本期节目，我能聊的时间就这么多了。我要说的是，我目前也正经历着类似的情况，我也需要遵循自己的建议。我想我录制这期节目有一半的原因是因为我刚好需要，怎么说呢，我需要热热身。
I need to get some strength in me and approach a situation that was like, that just become very complex. And sometimes when you lay it out like this, it just makes a lot more sense. and there is a reassurance there that like it is going to be okay. And I spoke to so many of my other friends and like even some like relationship experts for this episode who were like the biggest predictor of success in a relationship, in a friendship, in a friendship in families is how people manage conflict. And again, the sign that if you are willing to, the relationship most of the time does
我需要在体内积蓄一些力量，去面对一个变得非常复杂的局面。有时当你把这些事情一条条列出来时，一切就会变得清晰很多，并且会有一种让人安心的感觉，那就是一切都会好起来的。我和许多其他朋友聊过，甚至为这期节目采访了一些关系专家，他们都说：无论是在恋爱关系、友谊还是家庭中，预测成功与否最大的指标，其实是人们如何处理冲突。再次强调，如果你愿意去处理，大多数时候这段关系都能
survive. So that's the kick up the butt that I need. Hopefully it is helpful to you as well. I want to thank our researcher Lucy Davidson for helping us with this episode. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, hello, hi, thank you for being a loyal listener and making it to the end. Leave a little emoji down below. Leave the little friendship emoji, the little dancing girl emoji.
存活下来。所以，这就是我需要的临门一脚。希望它对你也有所帮助。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）协助我们制作本期节目。如果你坚持听到了这里，并且正在 Spotify 上收听，你好，嗨，谢谢你成为忠实听众并听到了最后。在下方留一个小表情吧。留一个友谊的小表情，或者跳舞女孩的小表情。
So I know you have made it this far and you are part of the elite club of like 5% of people who make it to the boring stuff at the end where I talk about how you can follow us on Instagram and how you can watch us on Netflix and how you can read transcripts of the episodes on Substack. Substack especially, I feel like is really helpful for this episode if you want to save this guide for the future, if you want to send it to somebody or you're somebody who processes this stuff over and over again through reading. It's all going to be in the description, but I just hope it's helpful. I hope it takes the stress and anxiety out of what I'm sure is a very stressful and anxious situation. I know you can do it. And I'm wish.
这样我就知道你坚持到了这里，并且你属于精英俱乐部——大概只有5%的人能听到最后这些枯燥的内容，也就是我在节目尾声介绍如何关注我们的 Instagram、如何在 Netflix 上观看我们、以及如何在 Substack 上阅读节目文字稿。尤其是 Substack，我觉得对本期节目特别有用，如果你想把这份指南保存下来留作将来参考，或者想把它发给别人，或者你习惯通过阅读来一遍又一遍地消化这些内容的话。所有链接都会在节目简介里，但我只希望它能对你有所帮助。我希望它能消除你在一场注定充满压力和焦虑的局中所感受到的压力和焦虑。我知道你能做到的。祝你
your luck but until next time be safe be kind be gentle with yourself we will talk very very soon there was no anything inside those eyes they turned black it scared the hell out of me people wake up
好运。但在此之前，注意安全，保持善良，对温柔对待自己，我们很快就会再聊。那双眼睛里面空洞无物。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓了个半死。各位，清醒点吧。
I'm the one that saw the murder take place by crevette and de pippo Anthony de pippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我才是那个亲眼目睹克雷韦特和德皮波行凶过程的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说我没有杀人。我要把这冤屈带进棺材里。在 Bone Valley 订阅源、iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》。
Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, Tune into these candid, uplifting and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。不过现在，有一个全新且令人兴奋的方法，可以开启你通往更多快乐生活之旅。这就是《Joy 101》。这是一个由我——霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的连线聊天。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio 应用程序，搜索 Joy 101 并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. Just honest, conversations about what it means, to be alive. I'm Javier El Chicharito
由 CVS 呈现的《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi》。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我是个人。从我出生开始，每一天我仍在学习如何带着问题、错误、人际关系和情感生活。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的和真诚的。只有关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托
Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts or whatever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an
·埃尔南德斯，请在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时会发生什么？这可不是一个
innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to deep cover the family man on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts here's something that should not be as complicated as it is getting a racist statue removed and here's something that should be a
无辜之人的表情。难道每个人都在对我是谁撒谎吗？我感到了如此绝望。我觉得这是我不得不做的事。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、apple podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《deep cover the family man》。这里有一件事本不该像现在这么复杂：拆除种族主义雕像；这里还有一件事应该比现在
whole lot easier than it is getting a new one put up in its place i'm akila hughes and rebel spirit season two is about both of those things as i was watching these statues come down i was thinking about what it meant that i grew up in a majority black city in which there were more or homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
简单得多：竖立一个新的来代替它。我是阿基拉·休斯，《叛逆精神》第二季就是关于这两件事。当我看着这些雕像倒塌时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里的奴隶主的纪念碑比被奴役的人还要多，这意味着什么。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《叛逆精神》第二季。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。